[Music]  you had a rare honor pay to uh louis ck  is a good friend of our show uh uh did a  routine recently that got a lot of  attention where he talked about meeting  you and being quite attracted to you in  fact very attracted to you yeah this got  a lot of attention i wanna i don't know  if you've seen this clip let's show this  clip very quickly  the one guy i would blow uh based on  based on who he is  is ewan mcgregor like seriously i'm not  gay in any other way except for i want  that guy right  totally  i'd like to say i'd like to see if he'd  put his money where his mouth is you  know  and i look forward to bumping into him  [Applause]  it's another way to raise money for  charity  that's right  everything goes